imagine out free of slaves oh my dad
thought today is the day skull-fuck
you're not from this realm no [__]
is it a problem only time will tell
guns magic you can't just choose I can
go both ways well that explains the
fetish where you bring it in I'll turn
you inside out
ass first clown
we're going to a party in hell what is
the occasion spawn celebrating your
eternal damnation
Sir John think again
toast based killer finally there how
many times I didn't kill you
my mission is determinate the undead and
back off we're on the same side how you
are also undead
[Music]
I was a just and compassionate Emperor
you massacred entire tribes and how did
you end up in hell you seem so familiar
like looking in a mirror
I like looking at one of questions
pendants winged me swords